ми отримуємо автобус для перевезення
особового складу
Зазначте автобус дуже нам допоможе
оскільки в неї комфортним і вмістими для
речей щоб в особовий склад міг
оперативно пересуватися
з точки б зараз парк ще старий є
Звичайно що малі транспортні засоби Але
такого Такого автобуса комфортного у нас
немає це буде вперше першим Я думаю що
надійним і прослужить там довго Так що
дякуємо фонду за отримане автобусів і
допомогу є така серйозна проблема на
фронті значить
бійцям де треба Потрібно десь митися
десь братися по-друге це ще питання суто
здоров’я особового складу оскільки
зрозуміло що в умовах якщо Ну не
дотримуються санітарії там починають
поширюватися хвороби тобто А це зміг
сміхом може виробити просто з ну з
бойового стану цілі підрозділи тому от
такий комплекс лаз неправильний Він дуже
потрібний в умовах фронту особливо там
де наприклад поблизу нема сіл немає
якихось населених пунктів де можна от
якось виїхати помитися випратися
привести себе до влади Ну плюс іще
зважуєте на те що і в населених пунктах
зараз в прифронтовій зоні не все гаразд
тому що там буває що цілі села сидять
без електрики що там нема вода
постачання тобто вот такий комплекс він
стає для багатьох підрозділів просто
порятунку от Тим більше що тут є
можливість і підключитися до електрики
там де вона є і якщо її взагалі нема то
розігріти воду просто дровами ну паливом
вот тут є генератор можна заживитися від
генератора Можна помити вибратися
посушитися можна помитися самому ну
тобто вот Власне кажучи те що на фронті
дуже необхідно і будемо говорити Так От
коли пояснюєш людям в тилу От такі речі
от часто стикаєшся з нерозумінням тому
що коли людям ну зрозуміло фонду
передають бронетехніку або автотехніку
ну це якось зрозуміло Да тим не менше це
от ті от дрібниці які дуже-дуже важливі
потому що ще раз повторюю особисто
відчуття людей їхнє здоров'я ну і
відповідно їхній бойовий настройки А нам
сьогодні привезли комплекс збиток на
послідовно називається це в якій входить
один пункт управління а також
страйкборди розвідувального трактора
мали досвід застосування вони себе
зарекомендували досить
Ну потужним інструмент розвідки
повітряної який на сьогоднішній день
необхідний А на полі воля і самі
комплекси посейдоне досить серйозно себе
зарекомендували у протидії якби вони не
такі до сьогоднішніх а-а засобів пройшли
навчання І от зараз ми отримуємо цей
комплекс може працювати в глибину
позиції до 50 кілометрів і це забезпечує
по-перше черга нам поінформованість про
ворожі дії про пересування їх
засобів ураження особового складу ми
використовуємо не тільки виключно для
розвитку для роботи нашої артилерії
в першу чергу потрібно
поінформованість тобто поінформований то
ти озброєний Привіт цей апарат має до
120 кілометрів
шляху тобто він може
пролітати за раз близько 120 км плюс від
станції управління він може відлітати на
50 км що дозволяє знаходитись у
безпечному місці під час виконання
бойових завдань
завдяки своїм характеристикам в тому
числі камери Він дозволяє дуже
далеко залітати до опозиції ворога і
проводити розвідки відповідно виявляти
особовий склад та вогневі засоби
противника для подальшої ураження нашої
артилерією Насправді Я би не сказав що
нам складно навчитися управляти це
досить доступна апаратура якщо можна так
сказати тобто складнощі жодних не
виникла навчання проводилося досить
інтенсивно У нас багато було саме
практичною роботи з управління
безпілотним апаратом в різних умовах
в умовах дії ребу вночі вдень при різних
погодних умовах і можу сказати що апарат
дуже зручний для використання
за будь-яких умов